[Musik]
sind Sie bereit für die neue Kampagne
grü jetzt grüne raus aus der Ampel sie
sind dabei oder nö danke schön aber was
was haben Sie denn mit FDP und SPD noch
zu gewinnen ganz viel wir hab eine große
Verantwortung zusammen jetzt bleiben Sie
doch mal steh ze mal die Kampagne
richtig grüit jetzt auch noch nicht meh
schön gemacht ja wie die Ampel dieser
Herr ist ganz klar für den grüsit er
möchte raus aus der Ampel das finde ich
auch mutig dass sie es aussprechen er
sammelt schon zehn Flyer inzwischen ein
weil er die alle verteilen möchte unter
den Delegierten zerreißen er ist der
Anführer der Bewegung grüet jetzt und er
zerreißt zerreißt den Flyer um damit
ausdrücken dass er die Ampel zerreißen
möchte er möchte die Ampel zerreißen er
möchte die Ampel zerstören nee das das
ist ja totaler totaler Quatsch oder
meine wir also klar wir sind nur
Menschen wir machen auch Fehler aber wir
machen auch den Unterschied sie wurden
ja mit großer Mehrheit wiedergewählt was
haben die Grünen gegen
sie ich glaube die Leute wollen einfach
Probleme lösen und ja ist nicht einfach
aber arbeiten haben Sie das Gefühl man
kann mit der Ampel noch Probleme
lösenter ich n also best ja z. Hause war
jetzt natürlich gezeich wir wollen ja
dass die FDP sozusagen eine Chance hat
und deswegen führen wir die Ampel bis
zum regionären wen sie den Satz einmal
in die Kammer sagen wir wollen dass die
FDP eine Chance hat wir wollen dass die
FDP eine Chance hat Herr hab haben sie
auch Zeit für uns nee hat er nicht ne ne
ja deswegen müssen wir uns halt mit
Leuten hier rumschlagen die kein
Ministeramt bekommen haben ja ganzrig ja
einfach mit so armseligen Ausschuss
vorsitzend aber sollten Sie die Ampel
jetzt nicht wirklich verlassen man kann
sich in der Opposition do auch super
erneuern ich meine selbst der Union
traut man wieder Regierung zu ja das ist
wirklich eine bittere das ist wirklich
das ist wirklich der Punkt der mich am
meisten ärgert genug ist genug ja s do
sagen sie auch einm die Kamera grü
jetztü jetzt mit mir ich bin
dabei ich habe jetzt gerade meine
Kampagne hier vorgestellt der grü jetzt
und ov hier ich frag einfach mal kurz
nach wie fanden sie es sehr gut also die
Leute finden die Idee sehr gut wir
müssen auch unsere Erfolge die wir haben
und die wir anstoßen die müssen
kommuniziert werden auf eine anständige
Art bitte welche Erfolge na die Erfolge
das eben jetzt gerade im im Gebäude
Energiegesetz ist ist schon ein Erfolg
dass man da was anstößt dass man raus
sie mein dass das völlig entkernt wurde
und das jetzt ohne soziale Förderung da
steht wegen des karsurteils dieses
Gebäude energ toller Erfolg können wir
zusammen feiern schlagen Sie ein toller
Erfolg ich sch ein es gibt nichts mehr
zu gewinnen für die Grünen es gibt noch
sehr sehr viel zu gewinnen für dieses
Land sie würden mir doch mal ein paar
Beispiele sagen was sie in der Ampel
noch durchkriegen könen soll ich mal
erstmal sagen was bes hingekriegt ne was
sie noch durchkriegen aber aber noch mal
wir haben sehr sehr viel schon
hingekriegt ja eben deswegen können sie
ja jetzt rausgehen mehr kommt da nicht
komm nicht mehr wir bleiben stark und
strong und fröhlich aus lauter trotz ja
und mit dieser Drohung gebe ich zurück
ST ja
Ciao hallo Youtube unten könnt ihr den
Kanal abonnieren er deutet nach unten in
die
Infobox neben mir gibt es weitere
interessante Videos Verlinkungen Komma
vielen
[Musik]
Dank